you're in charge of food i've been
planning a nuptial menu since the day i
met genevieve warning it will be
delicious and highly erotic your menu is
not gonna involve animal genitalia is it
no i was gonna make
not that
amy gina you came you think i'd miss
opening day of your food truck i'm your
biggest fan also your biggest investor i
guess she was freaking out she was gonna
lose a ton of money i told you that in
confidence you don't have that kind of
relationship well don't worry i'm
feeling good the one thing truck is
ready to serve the one thing yeah we
only served one thing the perfect
meatball sandwich made exactly the way
nana boyle used to i can't believe this
is finally happening
charles sorry i'm a bit stressed jason
and jeff the guys i hired to work the
truck called in sick so i'm all alone
what a fun opportunity okay boyle stop
freaking out i have the day off i can
step in and help yeah me too i'm not off
but i come and go as i please it's part
of my charm like an outdoor cat
okay i think we're ready for a practice
sandwich sounds good boss please call me
chef that's funny
chef thank you
okay see the cut is a little sloppy i
want you to cut it straight across no
big deal
again
yup slopey don't overthink it
again
now you're not thinking enough
again
still sloppy again
again you know what why don't we try
this why don't you just take that knife
put it to my throat and finish the job
do i look like jake to you do i look
like jake to you no not at all then why
are you trying to screw me oh my god
charles what is going on with you it's
chef you're not ready for this gina
you're up okay but i'm not calling you
chef and you're not yelling at me mm-hmm
there you go ah thank you no slope a
nice straight cut thank you i felt good
because the knife but you smushed the
bread it's too smushy
again order up chef
what is this why are you making six
sandwiches at once it's more efficient
now we're ready for the next five
customers who gives a hump about
efficiency the perfect meatball sandwich
is sauced exactly 70 seconds before
being served to maintain bread integrity
so sandwich number one will be fine but
sandwich number six will be a soggy turd
changing menu we're serving soggy turds
now get them while they're wet okay i
quit me too you're insane fine quit just
like jeff and jason did you told us they
got sick they got sick of hard work just
like you two get out you'll never cook
in this town again we're not chefs and
you never will be amy will you taste
this batter
hmm
i think it's a little off you know
what's hoth your mouth why jake lets
your stupid tongue anywhere near him
i'll never know
nope i forgot the sugar that's on me
hello boyle after you're done here meet
me in my office i have something i need
to ask you it's food related
i will bring my a-game
oh my god gina captain holt just asked
me into his office for a food-related
question yes i heard and that's how i
know i don't care i've wanted to build a
rapport with him since he got here but
until now all we've had in common was
our bank
guess who nypd hands up this is great
i had no idea captain holt was
interested in food i have zero interest
in food if it were feasible my diet
would consist entirely of flavorless
beige smoothies containing all the
nutrients required by the human animal
so our bank got some new atms huh i
wouldn't know i've switched banks ah no
anyway tomorrow's my
anniversary with kevin i'd like to cook
him an impressive breakfast could you
help
orient me with that process i'd be
honored preparing food for one's lover
is the most intimate gift of all
aside from washing their hair
you know many people think that
scrambled eggs are the easiest food to
make but that is incredibly foolish
they are a highly nuanced and
complicated dish okay now go ahead
and pour your eggs right into the pan
nice and slow
oh okay now what do i do oh boy okay we
hear that sizzle that means the heat is
a little too high on those eggs well the
the higher the heat the faster the eggs
cook the sooner kevin eats am i
incorrect no you make an excellent point
but we don't want to feed kevin burned
garbage
cooking is about patience
are you completely insane you never salt
can the pen the hand the hand is the
middle man okay
what you did is the culinary equivalent
of unprotected sex
you know what
you sir are not ready to scramble eggs
hand over your spatula
fine
i only wish in return i could get back
all the time i just wasted on this
futile project
i'm just gonna make kevin plain toast
for breakfast oh
that is low
hey boyle i smell bernie is hitchcock
roasting corn on the radiator again no
what you smell is the burning wreckage
of my relationship with halt so there's
no corner in the cob sorry i'm late guys
how to get my ax sharpened why do you
have an ax also nice ax thank you it's
for the turkey so i can chop its head
off when it gets here chop its head off
i ordered a live turkey it's being
delivered cause you know what they say
the yummiest turkey is the one that just
died in your hands charles you can't
kill an animal in here that's horrible
it's disgusting we won't let you do it
right amy it's getting late don't make a
mess relax it's not the first turkey
i've killed in a friend's bathtub it is
he
hey rosa the flatbush diner's pie is
terrible it's inedible
food is supposed to be edible so you
were lying what the hell boyle
put it in the socket bucket crust isn't
any better it's fancier but it's all
bells and whistles desserts
don't need to be clever they just need
to be good this
is the best pie in new york city
apple from argos bakery founded 1910
recipe unchanged taste it
damn it this is amazing this part is so
good i hate it you just graduated pisco
[ __ ] sorry i said [ __ ] i'm just
really worked up
i can't believe sal's is gone this place
is an institution it's the best pizza in
the neighborhood oh eighth best
yeah a tragedy i mean any food-related
crime is a tragedy like i said salz is
an institution and it's the best pizza
in the neighborhood i'm sorry jake sal
is only the eighth best i put out a
weekly brooklyn pizza ranking email
blast sal's has the fourth best texture
ninth best crust 12th best cheese and
honestly they're only seventh in
mouthfeel mouthfeel what is that the
inside of your cheeks are very sensitive
it's like the inside of your thighs
except with the tongue oh god look no
mario does pine needs work good
consistency on the crust but the cheese
and sauce ratio it's a travesty
do you have to spit in a word yes
amateurs go tasting they fill up and
they lose their palate by the third
slice i take this very seriously why are
you dragging sales pizza through the mud
that place is special why is it special
because it's the best pizza in the
neighborhood well according to charles's
email blast it's actually number eight
captain reads my blast of course it's
the only one that measures mouthfeel
what are you kidding right now now the
first step in learning how to cook is
learning how to taste so close your eyes
and open your mouth this isn't burning
man boil
tell me what i'm eating fine it's a
sharp vermont cabbage
now describe what you taste
cheese
and
cheese
okay that's good but try being more
descriptive i know you love peanut
butter and jelly sandwiches
why
their components have a long shelf life
they're cost-effective and they're so
simple a child could make them
okay
i was looking for more of an emotional
connection for example my favorite meal
is a simple roast chicken and potatoes
it was the only dish my mother knew how
to cook and when i eat it i feel as
though i am once again inside her womb
what's your story behind a pb j
i want a sandwich i make a sandwich i
eat
the sandwich bonjourno bonjourno pretty
cool stewm huh stem short for costume ah
all right let me guess you are dumpy
chuck norris no don't be ron weasley no
you guys stop it
he put thought into his costume and he
is obviously miranda from sex in the
city guys i'm mario batali malto mario
celebrity chef ginger prince of little
italy is he also a homeless troll doll
cause you look like a homeless troll dog
hey sweet battalion costume dude thank
you
there is a man with impeccable taste he
bit a guy's butt off at a wnba game
aristotle's from mask i'll take it
you